un nouveau bureau de Poste va fermer en
Indre-et-Loire celui de Sorigny dès cet
été ironie du sort cette fermeture
intervient dans une commune abritant
l'un des plus grands centres de tri
postal de la région résigné ses
habitants réclament une solution
alternative Clémence dosc un refrain
familier celui de la fermeture d'un
bureau de poste à Sorigny ou l'agence
est ouverte une dizaine d'heures par
semaine la fréquentation a chuté de 40%
en 7 ans le sujet sur la table depuis
septembre dernier mais des solutions
concrètes se font attendre par les
habitants un rassemblement est organisé
samedi prochain devant la poste pour
tenter d'obtenir des réponses la poste
dans le bourre c'est quand même un point
important un lieu où il s'est quand même
un service il y a beaucoup d'habitants
qui vont notamment ceux qui ont moins de
dispositif de mobilité en fait et du
coup c'est important de garder au moins
ce point dans le centre bourg se réuni
c'est une commune qui a 3000 habitants
bientôt donc il y a quand même du monde
quoi une solution vient tout juste
d'être trouvé l'ouverture d'un relais
chez une commerçantes la municipalité
attendait confirmation pour communiquer
au sujet de cette délocalisation des
services de La Poste à une centaine de
mètres de la mairie un point stratégique
au bord de la 910 et surtout des
horaires plus étendus je pense que le
transfert de la Poste se fera début juin
matondi le 6 juin exactement à la
promenade des gourmets
donc voilà je trouve qu'on a trouvé une
bonne solution qui permettra un service
public amélioré
auprès des soeurs Linois mais aussi
auprès de ceux qui passent sur la 910
d'ici juin prochain une partie des
locaux sera aménagée et dédiée au
service postaux vente de timbres envoi
de colis et petits retraits d'argent
pourront se faire parmi les fruits et
les légumes